welcome to another doctor Sadler's
honest review this is a series that is
devoted primarily to practical
philosophy understood in a broad sense
so it encompasses philosophy as a way of
life but also self-help leadership and a
number of other related fields the book
that I have to review today is one that
I highly recommend I'll tell you why in
just a moment and it's called this
happiness right blank pages on stoicism
and artistic creativity it is by a
friend and colleague Peter Stan couch
and it is the sort of book that were it
not for some disagreements that Peter
and I have on stoic doctrine and what
modern stoicism ought to look like I can
say I wish I'd written this book myself
and that that is sometimes the highest
praise that you can give as an author to
another fall out there it is quite
simply excellent and I'll tell you why
in just a few moments this is probably
the best book that I have reviewed in
this series up to this date
the first things that we need to explore
are the style of the author the
structure of the work and you might say
a summary of what the work is about so
let's start with the last one first the
the subtitle gives it away on stoicism
and artistic creativity Pyotr is
interested in the question of the
compatibility or incompatibility the
complementarity or contradictions
between stoicism as a practical
philosophy as a philosophy as a way of
life and artistic creativity understood
in several different senses so what he's
going to do in the work is examine that
question that's what the work is
fundamentally doing that's its job so
let's talk now about the structure of
the work and then we'll get to the style
of the author there's a really nice
introduction by the late Laurence Becker
who P oders studied with Laurence Becker
if you don't know who he is he's the
author of a new stoicism probably one of
the most important figures along with
say a long and and a few others Julia
honest perhaps to some degree in
bringing about a revival of interest in
stoicism among the academics but also in
a more popular sense so to have him
writing the foreword and recommending
the book and saying the arrival of this
book is good news is is quite something
then we have an introduction by pyotr
himself that you know frames the the
problem and we'll talk about that when
we get to themes he also tells you what
his methodology is and what you know he
means by artistic creativity then the
next section is called the argument and
this is sort of groundwork stuff he's
saying what it is that he intends to say
and you can find the argument
recapitulated more or less with a few
other additions in the conclusions parts
of the work at the end and then the rest
of the work which is not you know super
long it's less than 200 pages it's 158
all told the rest of the work is falling
into three main things the the the real
core of the text is all of these things
that pewter calls themes so you know
themes of you know making money you
could say themes of here we go theme of
fame the profit theme the preservation
theme we'll get into those in a bit each
of those is a section in which he's
considering some key idea that people
have about creativity and artists in
particular and he's examining to what
degree stoicism both in its ancient
conceptions and in its modern
reinterpretations is compatible with
that another thing that he has is a very
good index that not much need to be said
about that but I'll also point out that
he has extensive footnoting in here as
well as a bibliography and and which is
quite nice as well but the footnoting by
itself or the end noting rather the end
notes at an entire section are quite
good some of them are fairly long you
know perhaps half a page of rather dense
print and so he's giving you a lot to
work with there he's not just giving you
references
he's also adding some supplementary
ideas considerations for you
let's talk about the style of the work I
think that pewter is quite a good writer
I I enjoyed this quite a lot I think
that some contemporary readers may
struggle a bit in in working through it
but not a lot and I think that it's the
kind of work whose style is going to
make
you stretch rather than get in the way
and I have to say I quite like reading
this this work it's you know enjoyable
to read through there's a lot of
erudition there but it's framed in ways
that don't get in in the way that the
contemporary reader can find quite
valuable so I think you know that
probably is enough about style and
structure and summary
so what are the main ideas of this work
if you happen to pick it up it's as I
mentioned a little bit before it's
really oriented in the core around
considerations of what Peter is calling
themes and these are you might call them
features of a certain theory or approach
to a perspective on creativity that he
labels the romantic and the question is
whether these themes are in fact
compatible with stoicism rightly
understood not stoicism in a reductive
sense but but stoicism you might say
putting on its best face and so there's
there's a number of these different
themes in there and I should probably
just read through these and comment on
them a little bit so the theme of Fame
okay that that's pretty self-explanatory
many writers artists musicians pick
whatever creative kind of person you're
thinking of even shafts and people
working in other fields are often doing
what they're doing in order to leave
behind something that is going to
represent them and give them a kind of
you know immortality is that compatible
with stoicism that that's one of the
questions there the profit theme meaning
making money riches enriching yourself
in other ways is that going to be
compatible with stoicism the
preservation theme and the the
expressive theme these are quite
interesting as well now we're starting
to get into things that are a little bit
more jargony so it might be useful for
me to
tell you a little bit from the book so
he says the preservation theme is a
framework of understanding artistic
creativity as a means to capture some
specific fragment of the universe and
preserve it that's what what the idea is
so you know it could be I you know I
love this person over here so I'm gonna
paint their portrait and keep them
forever the the expression theme has to
do more with expressing yourself right
the and he considers two different
variants here the artist self created
through the creative act and the artist
self existing prior to it cognitive
theme art can tell us things art can can
convey ideas is that going to be
compatible with stoicism the
revolutionary theme that is art
political or social is it pushing a kind
of agenda about what it means to be
human and to live in community the axial
ah djegal theme this has to do with the
notion of art as generating or
responding to value and then finally he
discusses the auto therapeutic theme
right where you're using art to you to
express yourself but also to get a
handle on what's going on and your
messed-up psyche and then finally the
didactic theme where art is essentially
teaching us things so these are all
conceptions of creativity and art and
the production of it and the
appreciation of it and then the question
is well what is stoicism going to be
able to handle when it comes to these
and P odor well let's let's jump to the
conclusions because actually that that
section has a lot of great little
vignettes in which he lays out what it
is that he thinks about all this he says
that there we go the book produces two
conclusions the first one is clearly
ambiguous certain underpinnings of
artistic creativity can be agreed with
or they're compatible with stoicism
while others can
once we zero in on the specific themes
the result turns out to be about 50/50
and he says the second more concrete
conclusion of the book is that he says I
haven't found much evidence that the
ordinary mundane or non romantic
understandings of artistic creativity
were incompatible with stoicism but if
we're understanding creativity in a
romantic framework then there are going
to be some some real areas of both
tension and even contradiction and then
he also is going to use this to help
illustrate some some aspects of stoicism
so let's jump back you know early on in
the book he's got some some important
discussions that I'd highlighted and
wanted to bring up on page 17 he talks
about the stoic being viewed as
something like a happy Mills Pig Mill
had set Mills a utilitarian mill and
said that better to be Socrates
unsatisfied than a pig satisfied and you
know stoicism which is a Socratic
philosophy you know it one of the
fundamental aims of it is to enjoy
contentment or tranquility within one's
life by you might say reducing the areas
of painful vulnerability to
disappointment and contradiction and
things going wrong and living more
rationally there's there's that side of
stoicism stoicism also has definitely
has a socially oriented side because
they think of human beings as social
creatures so you know one of the worries
when thinking about creativity says is
that that a critic might bring up the
stoic was withdrawn doesn't account for
the complexity of human experience in a
word their humanity is painfully limited
and so if that were true well that would
be something really problematic about
stoicism so Peter wants to explore that
a little bit earlier we can talk about
the key question that he is framing here
he says that you know we do have to deal
with the fact that artist as he puts it
here artistic creativity is a challenge
to stoicism why well not least because
the ancient Stoics themselves did not
appear to have an awful lot of good
stuff to say about artistic creativity
you know we might think and pewter does
really touch on this quite a bit in the
work we might think of the life oriented
towards virtue and freedom and
tranquility that the Stoics are putting
forth as an ideal would itself
involve a lot of creative responses but
you know we might also differentiate
between creativity capital C that's
associated with artistic stuff and then
a more broad sense of creativity as well
so you know main ideas in addition to
those themes stoicism really does need
to grapple with this I mean there are
several possibilities open to the stoic
one would be to say ah you know can't
have artistic creativity or I can only
have limited amounts of it so much the
worse for artistic creativity let's just
focus on stoicism but that might lead
somebody to suspect that stoicism is not
as comprehensive and not as satisfying
to human beings as its proponents claim
it to be so P Oda really has his finger
on the pulse of an important issue here
and I think he's very good at working
through it so those are some of the key
ideas of this work
now we get to my favorite parts of these
review videos when the book is very good
and this book is indeed very good where
I get to talk up the the excellences the
high points the virtues if you like of
this particular text so to begin with
pewter is an incredibly competent
presenter of the the many different
things that he's bringing in and uniting
here this is a a work that is going to
have you probably following up and
reading other things not just classical
and to some degree contemporary Stoics
but boy peter covers a a really wide
range of other authors and theorists and
and phenomena it's really quite amazing
the breadth that is packed into this
rather thin volume and and much of that
has followed up on in the endnotes as I
pointed out and you know P order is
giving you just enough he's not
overwhelming you with the the references
that he's doing it's tougher to write a
really good short book than it is to
write a good long book for that very
reason and he managed to pull it off so
you know that's that's quite great he's
also good at pointing out what he is not
planning on discussing and I'll just
give you an example of that from early
on in the work one where he says I
extensively quote Seneca but only as
philosophical works I refrain from
analyzing the case of Seneca that is
from studying the twists and turns of
his life and how his philosophical
projects interacted with his playwriting
this is not a coincidence but a
thought-out methodological decision why
is that so I'm interested in an
intellectual inquiry into a well-defined
problem and not in a psychological or
biographical study of any individual
it's the possibility of a great clash
between
stoicism and romantic art that
captivates me not the fate or mindset of
any specific human so you know he's
setting himself some boundaries
methodologically and he's signaling to
you that he's not going to discuss that
similarly he brings up you know the
postmodern conceptions of creativity and
he says listen I'm gonna signal that
they're there and I'll even mention
Baudrillard a little bit but I'm not
going into that because that would that
would exceed the scope of my project and
take us away from that so you have you
know so you might say digressions with a
fence put up and you're actually a gate
in it saying well you can go on further
here if you want to we're just not going
to do that in this book and I think that
it's that's done particularly well
he points out a number of
misinterpretations of stoicism it talks
about for example the ascetic
misinterpretation he also talks about a
conservative misinterpretation Annie
explains what they are and I think he's
actually dead on we might we might
disagree in the terminology that we use
about that but these are some really
problematic
you know misinterpretations of this this
great philosophy another thing that I
think is a really strong point in the
work is that he resists the temptation
that is found in so much contemporary
stoic literature to what we might call
easy compatibility the idea that
stoicism can be anything you like you
know you've got something over there ah
stoicism could talk about that and bring
it in the pewter is is very measured in
this he's saying listen you know there's
some things where at first glance it
might appear that stoicism is probably
incompatible with that but you know
let's think it through and and we'll see
that no in fact it's not as a matter of
fact it might be complimentary but it
has to be understood in the right way
and then there's other things where no
it's not gonna work don't try to jam
these things together and say that you
still got stoicism left at the end
because you don't and
is a failure of a lot of contemporary
literature on stoicism this book does
not fall into that the other thing that
I want to bring up is that this is a
very well grounded and well-informed and
innovative reinterpretation of stoicism
so I think that this book you know years
and years and years from now when
somebody is doing a history from the
vantage point of you know 21 20 about
the modern stoic movement and some of
the prime texts and expositors of it I
think this book and Peter's work as a
whole will probably find their way into
that it's it's so well done again I
disagree with him on some things I know
for example the idea that we really the
the idea of in accordance with nature
that was so important to ancient
stoicism he and I have had conversations
about this he thinks we need to get rid
of that because it's just such a mess
lawrence becker again takes a more
moderate position of well we're kind of
stuck with it and i feel that way as
well
but I I can certainly where we disagree
I can certainly see the cogent see of
the position that he's taking and you
know this is this is a really great
focused reinterpretation of modern
stoicism that manages to carve out a lot
of room for incorporating creativity
into it so this is you know really
excellent stuff
what did I find problematic about the
work often I have a lot to say I'm not
gonna have very much to say here and
what I have to say is fairly trivial
because the book is you know very good
so the only two things that I have to
point out are these one is that there
are a few in Felicity's of expression
where you know you say well that's kind
of a weird way to say it or you know a
book that's that's from stoic literature
has been translated into English and and
the title that Pyotr is using doesn't
seem to be the title that we usually use
but I think that that can be attributed
to the fact that he's a native Polish
speaker and a second English as a second
language for him but those are pretty
rare in the book this this is more well
written in English than most native
English speakers works are in English so
that's really a testament that his his
capacities the other thing is a mere
form a thing you know the the various
themes he there's no page break that's
just you know one after another after
another and it's rather dense I think it
would have been nice to have page breaks
in there but that's that's a purely
preferential thing and you can easily
read the book just as it is I mean
there's a good table of contents there's
an amazing index there's great footnotes
so really I don't have much to say by
way of criticism of this book
final thoughts so this is a great book I
think that you need to get it if you're
interested in either of the two themes
that he's bringing together here
stoicism or artistic creativity I am
actually considering using this as a
text in a philosophical aesthetics class
it's that good and if you're interested
in modern stoicism I think this is a
must have quite frankly so I'll say this
too by way of final thoughts I only read
this this last month as I was preparing
for this Peter had it sent to me when it
first appeared in 2019 I put it into the
stack of books to review and thought
well that's I'm sure it's going to be
good this book is really just simply
excellent and as I said in the beginning
it's the sort of thing that I wish I had
written myself what Aristotle calls
jealous or emulation the pain that you
feel in seeing somebody else doing such
great work and wishing that could be you
instead doing that and enjoying the the
fact of having done that
that's this book it's that good so I
don't think I need to say much more
other than that to wrap this up it's
highly recommended
you